hi marvel fans i'm here with aryan moyet
how's it going how are you feeling i am
feeling overwhelmed excited i cannot
wait to see it on a big screen i'm like
over the moon about this whole thing how
does it feel to be a part of the mcu
it's surreal i'm not gonna lie to you
it's completely surreal to be a part of
marvel you know i was born in iran and
so to have that be from there to here is
a real surreal moment for me so i really
really uh
you know i'm just i'm just honored and
blessed really oh that's so good to hear
well i'm excited for you what are you
looking forward to most in the film
tonight
i am looking forward to my selfishly
i'm looking forward to my interrogation
with
ned spoiler okay okay um but most like
most what i'm really looking forward to
is watching tom holland and watching all
these folks make these amazing human
beings come to life i mean that's what
i'm looking forward to i mean this is
big this film everyone knows who peter
parker's uh secret identity is a
spider-man how does your character feel
about that obviously he does he's he's
interrogating him so he comes in and
really interrogates the group and really
kind of tells them listen
you shouldn't have done that you know um
anyway i'm really just excited to be
here and be a small part of this movie
[Music]
you